I would love to I just feel like you  have to do a lot of politics leading up  to it and you know no one ever has done  this just being a celebrity to just  being president that would be great but  if I have to like like work my way  I think we've realized you don't have to  yeah it is appealing yeah when I'm like  40 or 50. really yeah bro if I was a  billionaire and I just gave away all my  money I was like I can't be bought I  just give away every penny well  literally zero dollars my bank account  vote for me I feel like that's a pretty  good campaign thing like you're voting  for me yeah and just ignore lobbyists or  whatever 24 right now yeah it'd be like  three more Cycles I'd probably do it by  mid 40s yeah  I think I could make it interesting  enough where I could win okay well how I  know how to give people's attention I  can't say too much because then I'll  regret it in the future I'm thinking  yeah I'll just trick all the [ __ ]  idiots  that's literally what Trump said